emily works at a music store where she
repairs guitars she's been keeping track
of the types of guitars she's fixed and
the types of repairs that she's done
unfortunately emily has terrible
handwriting and when her manager asks
her for records she can't read all her
all of her numbers
the absolute and relative frequency
tables below show the numbers that emily
is able to read can you help her figure
out the rest so i've actually copied and
pasted the the absolute and relative
frequency tables right over here i've
copied and pasted it on my little
scratch pad and so we could do it right
over here
and so let's think through each of these
what's going on here so this is the
absolute frequency and here are the
relative frequencies so she couldn't
read this this plus this is going to be
that this so the broken acoustic strings
plus the acoustic neck repairs is going
to be the total acoustics that she's
done so these are the absolute numbers
and here are the relative numbers so for
example
the row percentage this tells us that
that this that this number right over
here is 61
of this number right over here and that
this number 70 is 38
of this number right over there so let's
let's work let's see if we can use that
information to figure out all this all
of this stuff out and as always i
encourage you to pause this video and
try to figure out try to see if you can
think of it think of it on your own
so just to simplify things i'll just
give all of these letters just so that i
can keep track of them so i'll call this
let's call this a
let's call this b
let's call
i don't know let's call this c
and let's call this d
and then they are saying that this right
over here is x x is this value right
over here so we'll we'll just leave that
as x
so let's see what we could figure out
so let's say we wanted to figure out so
we know that we she fixed
70 broken electric strings and that's 38
of the total
of the total strings of the total broken
strings that she fixed so one way to
think about this is 70.
let me circle this in a color i haven't
used yet
70
over b
over b this is going to be the
percentage of the broken strings she
fixed which were electric and they tell
us that right over here that's going to
be
38.89 percent so that's going to be
equal to we could either say 38.89 or
38.89 over 100 or we could even write
that down as 0.389
this is clearly the same thing this is
the same thing as
38.89
so how do we solve for b here well we
could multiply both sides by b and you
get 70 is equal to 0.388
times b
or that b just divide both sides by
0.3889
b is equal to 70
over
eight 0.3889 and we could get our
calculator out for that so let me clear
that so we have 70
divided by
0.3889
is equal to
179 now she she wouldn't fix a fraction
of a broken string here so i think it's
safe to say that we we should round to
the nearest whole number so it looks
like she fixed a total of 180
180 bro or b is 180 or she fixed a total
of 180 broken strings so let me do that
in that blue color
so this b is equal to
180. well if b is equal to 180 we know
that a plus 70 is equal to 180 so a must
be 110
180 minus 70 is
110
and now we can figure out c c is going
to be 110 plus 21
which is 131
131 and then finally
d
is just 180 plus 82 which is equal to
262.
so all we have to do now is figure out
what x is so let's see x is
x is the percentage
so if we look at neck repair acoustic
neck repair column percentage so
acoustic neck repair
acoustic neck repair right over here and
it's the percentage of the column so we
want to say what percentage is 21 of 131
so x if i'm thinking about this right is
going to be 21 divided by 131 and we can
confirm that we're reading it right
because 61
61 divided by
131 needs to be equal to this column
percentage so let's just verify that
we're reading this this chart correctly
so 61 divided by
131
is equal to 46.56
which is exactly what we have there so
to get x we just divide 21 by 131.
21 divided by
131 is equal to
16.0 let's see everything they're
rounding in terms of percentages they're
rounding to the nearest hundredth so
hundredth of a percent so 16.03
16.03 percent so x is
x is 16.03
percent and so
i think we are done